how do you know that an idea is
brilliant at which stage when did you
know it was a good idea
um
[Laughter]
and maybe is there like some
phase shifts first your complete doubt
and maybe hmm
and then maybe it becomes more than
and becomes like a little more
confidence that kind of stuff and also
wisdom about who to talk to
right uh so they don't trample the idea
in the early stages that kind of stuff
and you thought about this we could go
on again how long do you want to go
this is a netflix series i told you
multi-season
so a lot of lessons learned over those
years of failure and and success but
the first thing it starts with
um there's a whole chapter called great
ideas chase you and so kind of goes into
in build and you can go and it goes
through kind of chapter and verse about
all of those how nest became into being
but let's talk about it specifically for
ipod right so for me
i always had pain the pain of carrying
these cds everywhere right and i had the
joy of music
right
if you could say all of a sudden i could
get the music i love all the time
in a portable package and i can have all
the music i love all the time i was
solving a pain which was for me it was
thousands of these other people might be
10 or 15 cds right and then i can have
the joy of all this music uninterrupted
that was that was taking the pain
making a painkiller for it and then at
the end was a superpower an emotional
superpower that said oh my
this is something different so when you
can actually
focus on a pain not of not and and get a
painkiller for it not a vitamin so the
difference between a painkiller and a
vitamin is very clear one you need i got
to get rid of this pain a vitamin
maybe it works maybe it doesn't maybe
somebody needs it maybe not it's all
marketing story right so you start with
the pain give them a painkiller and
hopefully if you can do it in the right
way you give them a superpower an
emotional superpower
that is always and that's the way to to
to know that you're hitting on something
that's really powerful the pain and the
joy exactly um are you always aware
of the pain
so it seems like a lot of great products
it's like we do a lot of painful things
and we just kind of assume
that's the way
it's supposed to be like what's much
autonomous vehicles we'll all assume
we're supposed to be driving right like
and it doesn't
you don't think of it as a pain
right well you've you've habituated it
away yeah you've habituated way for me
you know when i go uh to other places
living in bali or living in paris or
whatever and i'm not driving
i'm walking or using a scooter or what
have you different thing and you go oh
my god when you left that environment
because everyone else is driving all the
time you're like that's what you do and
you find out there's other ways of
living and there's freedom when you get
rid of that you're like oh my god i
didn't know
that this was so much better so there's
there's something in the book that's
called i i deemed it the virus of doubt
and what the virus of doubt is
is when there's pain and it's been
habituated away
you use the right marketing messages
to
to bring people back to that initial
experience they had or the initial
experience that they had of that pain do
you remember when the first time you did
blah and it felt like this
right and then you reawaken
that habituated pain
and people it becomes visceral and then
they're like oh
yes i hate that
and then you go
now i have the painkiller and the joy
for you yes that's when it all comes
together and it goes
you